dottore pronto per scalata incredibile
sul kahn oggi totò rialzato alle quattro
e mezza del mattino come vecchi tempi
perché eto'o trova esperto in scalata
sindaco dove è preparato zaino con
crauti e wurstel bussola dottore con
lava di vulcano farle anche caffè
andiamo
[Musica]
totò che scherzava non poter fare a
scalata di cannes al parcheggiatore no
esperto dottore muscoloso solo in
cervello
oggi totò e costruire vulcano su questo
tavolo e utilizzava in un micro dottor
al posto di te toro vero e proprio che
posizionarle sul vulcano e rotante sei
dottore forte prove sopravvive oggi totò
rifare esperimento molto molto difficile
come se gli altri non lo fosse insegnata
e poi sarà inferiori possa essere
vulcano cosa dice luca non appena nato
ma qualcuno mi dia steccata di legno
presto per fare un grande 89 mettere
all'interno di caraffa sapone per piatti
mettere alto sapone per piatti per fare
restante parte di tappa con l'aceto
adesso il dottore mescolare a totale
prima inserire il resto per ciò che è
dimenticato quanto troverà mentre tutto
dovrebbe smettere poca banda tirare
miscuglio non capire già cosa starà
facendo e vito la primizia per creare
cultura di vulcano dottore utilizzare
cassetta scegliere singola pagina da
accartocciare poter creare cultura
una volta preso ben 18 giove fare false
tipica mentre dottore costruire cano per
passare tempo da dove ascoltare radio
tedesca poi fredda
[Musica]
no è finito col cane completamente senza
aiuti per lo scollo paio di effettivo
tempi 1934
per capire che attendere basso
[Musica]
caro quasi completato mancare ovviamente
emozione di feeling bicarbonato dover
inserire bomba di carnato denko vulcano
ma per deliziare il bomber il carbonato
creiamo croce di carte di culo inserire
diversi cucchiai di bicarbonato in carta
igienica per bomba tipica una cosa più
importante vediamo se totò rea miniatura
sopravvive o muore dottore adesso pronto
per esperimenti tortore sentire
adrenalina
[Musica]
poi non solo sopravvissuto
sto bene e vulcano finalmente funzione
incredibile non fatelo a casa amici
esseri inferiori perché sennò poter
avere problemi in famiglia dottore
assicurare totale sopravvissuto a
esperimento quindi sotto al è
disponibile per altro sperimenti
incredibile quasi mese prima aspettare
concluderà video qua che vi sia piaciuto
sociale pollicione in alto come sempre
dà appuntamento ad una prossima lezione
di cose belle maschere
[Musica]